bonsoir alexis et on commence tout de
même par des constats ça fait du bien un
petit peu plutôt réjouissant locaux
vides en france clairement la situation
s'éclaircit et s'améliore à ce stade oui
alors à ce stade moins de 2000 personnes
sont en réanimation 1900 environ et les
chiffres depuis quelques semaines sont
du côté de la baisse c'est à dire que
soit la campagne de vaccination a
fonctionné soit le passenger fonctionner
soit le virus est moins virulent
toutefois et il est question maintenant
de revoir effectivement l'ajustement de
ses politiques sanitaires parce que les
chiffres sont bons et tant mieux je
pense qu'après deux ans de kovy d'un
rappelez-vous décembre 2019 covit 19
maintenant nous allons bientôt arriver
en octobre 2021 il est temps de passer à
autre chose et évidemment la vaccination
est arrivé entre temps les connaissances
aussi sur ce virus la façon dont il le
mute dont ils occupent les corps des
humains permettent aujourd'hui de se
dire qu'en france on peut quand même
commencé à faire autre chose le pass
annie terre il a été mis en place
pendant l'été pour éviter que la rentrée
soit une catastrophe
de de contamination est évidemment il y
a eu 3000
pas trop mais je n'ai pas le chiffre
exact mais beaucoup de classes fermées
mais finalement on a l'impression que la
rentrée n'est pas l'explosion de
l'épidémie qui aurait pu être la crainte
des soignants certains parlaient de
50000 contamination par jour dans les
écoles on est loin de ce cas on est loin
de cette de ceux de ces chiffres là et
heureusement et donc emmanuel macron
peut lâcher la bride et dire que
éventuellement se passe à intervalles
être allégé dans les semaines qui
viennent autre raison aussi c'est que la
reprise économique ne pourra pas être au
rendez-vous si le passe à lithaire est
toujours présent et toujours aussi
pesant que ce soit sur le secteur bien
sûr du divertissement des restaurants et
du reste il faut aujourd'hui que les
français retrouvent une sorte de vie
normale même si elle ne sera pas normal
puisque le covin est toujours présent
donc gestes-barrières le à ce que la
vaccination est aujourd'hui est-ce que
le passé littéraire a encore un sens oui
selon certains mais pour un président en
campagne il est temps peut-être de lever
les barrières alors ce qui nous conduit
tout de même à une question alexis avec
notre esprit retors à vous et à moi
emmanuel macron ne fait-il pas tout même
une nouvelle fois dû en même temps d'un
côté 3000 soignants suspendu de l'autre
le pass alléger
alors on n'a pas l'esprit retors je
pense qu'on est simplement critiques et
qu'on fait un travail exigeant de
journalisme et le journalisme c'est quoi
c'est poser des questions au moment où
il faut poser des questions et apporter
des réponses avec des preuves
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
d'un côté olivier rang ministre de la
santé est très fier de dire que 3000
soignants ont été suspendues parce
qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés et que
plusieurs dizaines d'entre eux alors je
pense que les chiffres sont revues à la
baisse 1 d'ailleurs ont démissionné le
problème c'est que quand on a de tels
chiffres et qu'on est ministre de la
santé on ne peut pas s'en réjouir ça
veut dire que l'hôpital est en train de
s'effondrer que il ya des services qui
vont fermer que ce soit les dialyses que
ce soit les services de radiologie que
ce soit des services où on va faire des
diagnostics
on peut pas être heureux de dire qu'il
ya moins de soignants en france alors
que l'hôpital est déjà sous pression
donc on est effectivement dans un en
même temps tragique ou d'un côté il faut
le bâton et de l'autre la carotte or ça
ne marche pas dans une situation de
crise comme le co vide on ne peut pas
être réjouis de dire que 3000 soignants
sont suspendus quand on a encore des
malades 2000 malades environ qui sont en
urgence et quand ce virus continue
d'être là donc évaluer le maquereau est
en train de dire on est méchant mais on
est gentil en même temps vous avez
bientôt être libéré de cette gangue
qu'est le pas salutaire tout va bien se
passer ne vous inquiétez pas donc c'est
un peu le jeu du good cop bad cop qu'on
connaît dans les séries américaines qui
se joue à la française en dix ans on est
méchant à côté mais gentil de l'autre
donc il faut que vous soyez patients les
français et les pales les français sont
patients vraiment parce que ce qui se
passe c'est jouer avec les nerfs en fait
de la population en disant pourquoi
faut-il vacciner des enfants pour qu'ils
aillent jouer au foot au tennis qu'ils
aillent dans des clubs de judo alors que
de l'autre côté il ne risque rien et
pourquoi deux côté on mobilise on
immobilise les soignants parce qu'ils
n'ont pas choisi de se vacciner il ya
vraiment quelque chose de l'ordre de
l'ubuesque dans la politique sanitaire
depuis le début la presse étrangère
allemande par led absurdistan
autoritaire on est en plein dans le dur
de l'absurde distant et autoritaire
aujourd'hui avec la suspension des
soignants d'un côté et le fait que le
virus les chiffres sont bons et ne
permettent pas de dire que ces mesures
ont un sens aujourd'hui ces mesures
avaient un sens peut-être dans l'été
pour que les gens soient poussées la
vaccination est le sens du passé
éternité que ça pousse et les gens la
vaccination or la vaccination a ses
limites et or le virus va continuer donc
il va falloir lâcher du lest parce que
voir entrer bientôt en campagne et vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir stéphanie
chemtech macron est un candidat
permanent en campagne et là on le sait
ça devient évident avec ces annonces
aujourd'hui justement j'allais y venir
avec mon esprit critique on va dire hé
wenna qu'on serait jouée par l'ong de
lever un sofa sanitaires mais d'autres
quand même autour de lui en sont plus
prudents le conseil scientifique au ou
même son ministre de la santé olivier
veyron c'est donc un président comme
vous dites non officiellement campagne
qui parle mais c'est encore un pari
qu'il prend emmanuel macron alors je
pense que départ il en a pris beaucoup
effectivement le premier pari c'était
quand même de dire aux français d'aller
au théâtre à une semaine de faire le
confinement absolue là c'était vraiment
le plus gros paraît qu'il ait jamais
pris ensuite ça a été une appropriation
de chaque instant il ya peu de paris des
macros en réalité il a essayé d'être ce
leader autoritaire absolue qui gère par
conseil de défense et d'être en même
temps le soignant le soignant absolue
qui donne des cadeaux qui dit aux
français qui les cajole en regarder ma
politique est tellement bonne que
maintenant vous pourrez sortir de votre
cage et c'est exactement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ne soyons pas dupe il sait
très bien que s'il veut gagner la
présidentielle de 2022 parce qu'il va se
représenter ne sommes pas du tout non
plus clairement et mâcon n'a pas
l'intention de ne pas se représenter
comme françois hollande aujourd'hui donc
il fait tout pour lisser son image pour
colmater les brèches là où tout le monde
pourrait l'attaqué et ouroux est-ce
qu'on peut l'attaquer sur la sécurité
d'abord il a fait le de la sécurité
cette semaine il était à roubaix pour
expliquer qu'il était le président de la
sécurité et la deuxième attaque qui
serait évidente c'est sur sa gestion de
cette crise qu vide qui a été
calamiteuse rappelez-vous le nous sommes
en guerre devant un hôpital militaire
sur un parking d'un supermarché dans
l'est de la france qui n'avait aucun
sens c'était simplement de la mise en
scène là aussi on pourrait le critiquer
en disant qu' il n'avait pas de masque à
l'époque et que sa porte parole cib et
mbia il disait que les masques étaient
inutiles et que olivier derand ministre
de la santé lui même disait qu'à
l'époque les masques étaient inutiles
aujourd'hui les masses ils sont présents
partout ils sont un élément clé de la
lutte contre le coc vide donc le
mensonge et l la manipulation et
l'improvisation est telle qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron doit faire en sorte
qu'ils il est maintenant le président
qui a vaincu qu'ovide donc aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il fait il dit que sa
politique est formidable que les
chiffres sont bons que les français vont
pouvoir après le passé ni terre
retrouvée non pas la vie d'avant mais
une vie adapté à la vie qu vide et donc
c'est ce qu'il fait en tant que candidat
permanent il est le good cop et ses
ministres vont être les bad cop comme le
conseil sanitaire qui sera là pour lui
rappeler que peut-être qu'il est trop
tôt pour aujourd'hui dire que le passé
l'inter n'a plus de raison d'être donc
on n'en est pas là évidemment dans le
passé l'inter est toujours très présent
mais on voit bien que il y a une volonté
de se positionner comme celui qui veut
libérer les français alors que c'est lui
même emmanuel macron qui nous a enfermés
avec des autos attestation de sortie
avec des amendes quand on allait se
balader en forêt des amendes sur la
plage quand on voulait se poser sur les
plages de france
n'oublions pas comment le coc vide a été
un moment de n'importe quoi pendant des
mois parce que l'exécutif mais pas
seulement en france partout dans le
monde ne savais pas comment réagir face
à cette nouvelle maladie aujourd'hui on
a des moyens de lutter on connaît un peu
mieux le coville et idées maintenant en
france clair que la campagne
présidentielle a commencé et qu'elle
aime un grand compte bien être candidat
président et voilà pourquoi il fait ses
annonces et voilà pourquoi les ministres
et le conseil de défense sanitaire est
aussi
bah de doute finalement deux de ses
choix aujourd'hui merci beaucoup alexis
poulain d'avoir été avec nous avoir
apporté votre analyse